this tastes like I'm gonna be peeing in
a parking lot in public later tonight
it's taste like pee in a parking lot
we're drinking vodka that's supposed to
taste better because it's gone through a
filter but one of them is gonna taste
like [ __ ] one of these is filtered once
through and one of them filter twice yes
and then one is unfiltered I'm really a
whiskey person so I'm not looking
forward to any of this same I'm
expecting severe PTSD back to like my
freshman year how much filtering can
like get rid of bad memories okay
I actually didn't hate that well no
didn't burn oh I could have shot that
entire thing and not actually I'm gonna
shoot the whole thing I've had shitty
cheap vodka and it's not it's worse than
that I think that was filtered once ah
don't be bad yeah that wasn't good I
think that was worse you know that
feeling when you get soda and then you
burp and it goes into your nose oh
that's so much worse that this piece of
[ __ ] wasn't filtered at all last but not
least Oh
that's not as bad as this one this one
that one wasn't bad
quick Russian lesson vodka translates to
sweet water and this is what this was
the most like this will get your friends
if you bring this to a party 100% the
second one is unfiltered and one of
these is filtered twice first one was
definitely the worst one so that was
filtered none filtered a bunch of times
filtered zero times filtered one this
one was filthy once this one's
unfiltered and this one was filtered
twice okay it work it works like a good
college I shouldn't say that but like we
all [ __ ] drink let's just be real
give me bourbon any day of the week you
don't need this filter or whiskey think
about it
be careful with this I know it seems
like it's the cheapest option and you
know you're in that liquor store and
it's ten dollars but just be careful
okay at least put it through the filter